let's be direct we can't solve a problem
without first identifying it the problem
in our country right now authoritarian
leaders who are so hell-bent on gaining
power and keeping it by whatever means
necessary that they're directly
attacking our freedoms in state after
state it is mind-boggling sometimes it's
just flat out insane yeah and what you
start to realize is the Democrats are
always looking to fill their narrative
the facts don't matter the issue does
not matter it's what's going to fill the
narrative none of that matters only
thing that matters is either
perpetuating The Narrative or protecting
their narrative and that's one of the
saddest things that we see up here on
Capitol Hill what's happening in those
red States
it's not who we are it's Un-American
it's undemocratic he is such a piece of
mother
he's such a lying Dirtbag everything
that Gavin Newsom says is the reverse of
the truth